it's hard to be excited about the
benefits of a cucumber but let's talk
about cucumbers in general now sometimes
i will switch it up instead of having a
big salad i'll have a couple cucumbers
and
it's interesting because the cucumber
has 73 different phenolic compounds
which are just a type of phytonutrient
and another unique thing about cucumbers
is they have certain phytonutrients that
are in cruciferous vegetables but not in
other vegetables except cucumbers now
there's five basic benefits from
cucumbers health-wise they help
stabilize your blood sugars they help
stabilize your cholesterol by helping
reduce ldl increasing hdl decreasing
triglycerides
also they're a good anti-inflammatory
they are loaded with antioxidants very
powerful antioxidants all these right
here and plus they provide fiber to make
butyrate so your microbes
can take that fiber and turn it into
small chain fatty acids and this helps
with insulin resistance it feeds the
colon cells it gives the colon cells
energy
now the question is how do we extract
these phytonutrients and a lot of them
are
fat soluble now in order to extract
these from plants
there's three main things you can do
one
is you can ferment
them okay when you ferment a vegetable
now that's different from pickling which
i'll talk about in a second when you
ferment them
you actually release
more
phytonutrients you make more
phytonutrients available for you to use
so
when you go to the grocery store the
great majority of pickles
are basically just cucumbers with some
added acid when you do that you do not
enhance the phytonutrients you don't
make them more available
now
when you eat pickled anything it's going
to help your digestion to some degree
but you're not going to get the maximum
benefits of getting these right here
but when you ferment them
you will
so one of the brands that i recommend is
bubbies pickles they have sauerkraut
really high quality product and that's a
true fermented product where
they add a bacteria lactobacillus and
then what happens it ferments
the carbohydrate and you get lactic acid
it takes longer
but you have the release of these
phytonutrients so i would always
recommend if you're going to eat pickles
go with the fermented pickles it should
say it right on the label you'll just
get more
health benefits
so that's the first way to extract these
fat soluble phytonutrients from
vegetables the next way is to steam them
a little bit don't overcook them but
when you steam them you will also
release some of the phytonutrients which
is interesting
and the last thing you can do
is you could eat them with fat
and what i do is i do cucumbers with
hummus not the
typical hummus that has the soy oil or
even the safflower oil i want it with
the olive oil so i get my hummus from
the farmer's market or i will go to a
healthy store to find it
but adding some of the tahini butter
which isn't a fat with
cucumber will help you extract these
phytonutrients now you can also add
olive oil so you cut your cucumber on
your salad add olive oil and you'll
extract it that way as well but these
are the three ways to enhance the
phytonutrients from plants in general
thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no brains no sugar totally keto
there's no suffering in keto absolutely
not karen and it's an immune system
builder absolutely you have to check
this out i think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto but is it
simple it's super simple we hope you
enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it